et pour en parler nous sommes avec eux
olivier delorme historien auteur de la
grèce et des balkans aux éditions
gallimard bonsoir olivier de tension
avec plaisir à ses côtés mezri haddad
ancien ambassadeur à l'unesco président
du centre international de géopolitique
de prospective analytique bonsoir à vous
les riad haddad
tout d'abord je souhaiterais connaître
votre regard sur ce qui est en train de
se jouer à cette frontière
écoutez je pense qu'il faut commencer
par dire aux français qu' il y à ici une
grande confusion sur ce qui se passe
entre la grèce et la turquie ce qui se
passe entre la grèce la turquie n'a rien
d'un mouvement spontané c'est un
mouvement organisé par un gouvernement
despotique et islamistes de monsieur
erdogan qui est en difficulté sur tous
les plans l'économie de son pays est à
l'arrêt a connu une grave récession
depuis la fin de 2018 le système
clientéliste sur le quai les fonds de
charité islamique sur lequel est fondée
ce régime est en panne et
erdogan tente en syrie et en lybie de
ressouder l'opinion derrière lui dans
des aventures qui sont de plus en plus
périlleuse et se trouvant en difficulté
il envisage sa il a déclenché cette
invasion migratoire il faut pas il faut
il faut employer les mots 1
il faut nommer les choses il s'agit pas
d'un mouvement migratoire il s'agit
d'une tentative d'invasion d'un pays
souverain qui appartient à l'union
européenne et qui vise à imposer à ce
pays
l'accueil de dizaines ou de centaines de
milliers de gens qui ne sont pas des
réfugiés politiques et et ce mouvement
est organisé de longue main puisque
depuis plus de dix ans maintenant
monsieur erdogan a supprimé les visas
d'entrée sur le territoire turc pour une
soupe pour environ 70 pays et il y
concentre une masse de gens dont il se
sert aujourd'hui d'une manière
particulièrement cynique et agressive à
l'égard de la grèce
alors je pense qu'il faut arrêter de
poser cette question en termes
humanitaires et qu'il faut la poser dans
les termes politiques et géopolitiques
où elles doivent être posées la grèce
est aujourd'hui victime d'une agression
et elle a le droit de légitime défense
d'employer tous les moyens à sa
disposition pour stopper cette agression
mezri haddad vous êtes d'accord avec
olivier delorme
il faut voir les choses pas devenir
humanitaire mais
et non écoutés omani terre on peut le
voir individuellement personnellement et
nous tous je suppose et j'en suis
persuadé on ne peut qu'éprouver que des
sentiments de compassion vis-à-vis de
toutes ces personnes de ces milliers
d'individus qui sont entassés et mais
qu'il soit instrumentalisé d'une série
chère alors là justement il y a il y a
des des liens de causalité entre la
guerre que erdogan
l'islamiste et les frères musulmans mène
contre la syrie et ce n'est pas
d'aujourd'hui c'est depuis 2011 n'est ce
pas sauf qu'elle était à part des
groupes islamistes et terroristes
interposés maintenant il s'engage il
engage ses armes et là bas il y a un
lien de cause un de causalité entre le
conflit armé entre l'armée l'armée
syrienne et l'armée turque est
l'ouverture de ce j'allais dire pas et
plein humain n'est ce pas parce que
erdogan veut faire pression sur l'europe
mais pas seulement par rapport à la
question migratoire c'est et par rapport
à l'argent d'ailleurs parce qu'il n'en a
pas eu assé monsieur erdogan de l'argent
du contribuable européen n'est ce pas
donc il veut davantage d'argent mais il
veut surtout un soutien militaire il
l'est de l'europe et deux le temps dans
le conflit où il n'a plus rien à faire
parce que erdogan comme l'ensemble des
pays qui se sont engagés dans la
destruction programmatique de la série
depuis 2011
ils ont été défaits alors les pays
civilisés devrez reconnaître cette
défaite et ce n'est pas une honte compte
quant à l'obstination de monsieur
erdogan c'est dans sa nature
le jusqu'au boutisme n'est ce pas
aujourd'hui cette question là il faut la
traiter avec fermeté et et avec tous les
outils politiques diplomatiques et
sécuritaires
l'europe ne devrait pas donner encore
plus d'argent à monsieur erdogan
même s'il s'agit d'une question
humanitaire elle devrait donner de
l'argent et du matériel et du renfort à
la grèce et à la bulgarie pour kiel pour
qu'il retienne cette invasion cette
déferlante migratoire
ça ressemble vous savez en d'autres
temps ça aurait de saint roch saint
honoré qualifie cette action d'acte de
guerre parce que et il n'est pas moins
qu'un acte de guerre je lui ai donné
cela brise et api la turquie qui nie 1
ce soir utiliser les migrants pour faire
chanter l'union européenne dont je ne
sais pas si beaucoup vont croire
monsieur erdogan sur ce coup là l'europe
qui ne cédera pas face à ankara des
rêves frontières resteront fermées aux
migrants c'est ce que nous dit le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères c'est le début d'un bras de
fer au lieu et de larmes qui lui allait
jusqu où le ministre des affaires
étrangères serait un peu plus crédible
s'il ya une semaine ils n'avaient pas
féliciter les turcs et assurer les turcs
de notre entière solidarité en syrie on
peut quand même relevé l'incohérence
totale de la diplomatie française dans
cette dans cette affaire qui un jour
assure l'entière solidarité de la france
avec monsieur erdogan et qui le
lendemain a sur l'entrée et solidarité
de la france avec la grèce qui est
agressé par la turquie donc si vous avez
eu lieu en même temps de monsieur macron
a quand même des limites en matière
diplomatique
et quand on dit du jour au lendemain une
chose et son contraire
on n'est pas vraiment crédible l'autre
chose que je voudrais vous dire c'est
que l'union européenne serait un petit
peu plus crédible en disant qu'elle ne
cédera pas au chantage si elle n'y avait
pas déjà cédé de manière systématique
depuis dix ans il faut quand même que
les gens sachent que entre les 6
milliards donnés par madame merkel sur
son propre de son propre chef et qu'elle
a en ce sens avoir été mandaté par
l'union européenne puis que les
européens ont accepté de payer à
monsieur erdogan en 2015
quand il ya eu le pr un des premiers
épisodes de ce chantage
que on a déversé sur la turquie des
milliardaires au titre de la
delà de la préparation au marché unique
de la réalisation du marché unique puis
au titre de la pré adhésion à l'union
européenne que cet argent là c'est
milliards on les a donnés à la turquie
en même temps qu'on écorchait la grèce
de l'autre côté et que leur groupe dans
une totale 1 1 dans une totale
incohérence affaiblissez la grèce en
finançant monsieur erdogan
il faudrait quand même qu'on mette fin à
ces incohérences au niveau européen
si on veut être un peu crédible vous
comprenez bien que quand on paye un
maître chanteur
ça veut dire qu'on l'encouragent à
continuer son chantage
alors que faut-il faire est venu en
urgence des ministres un aujourd'hui
même à bruxelles et son pied du mur
quelles sont les marges de manoeuvre
mais vrille haddad sont je ne sais pas
s'il y a encore moyen de discuter
diplomatiquement et politiquement avec
erdogan et sans régime islamiste
je crois qu'ils sont désormais dans une
autre logique
le seul langage que monsieur erdogan
comprends c'est le langage de la force
et lui ils l'utilisent et help us de la
force de la puissance parce qu'il fait
de la politique
certains dirigeants je crois qu'ils ne
sont plus qu'ils ne font plus de
politique savait ce que disait ce que
disait karl schmidt ou julien freud
n'est ce pas un philosophe un philosophe
politique il n'ya pas de politique
possible sans la désignation de l'ami et
de l'ennemi tout le monde occidental n'a
plus d'ennemis il fait plus de politique
mais lui monsieur horten son connaître
bien sûr carl schmitt encore fragile et
iphone il fait de la politique alors le
seul langage c'est celui de la fermeté
alors l'ex monsieur c'est quoi la
fermeté je m'explique pas ce que c'est
cette tragédie humaine
il en est lui même responsable
n'est ce pas c'est pas celui qu'on
appelle tout le temps et encore
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment affligeant
quand j'entends ça sur certaines
télévisions dans certains journaux le
régime
de bachar la république arabe syrienne
n'est pas vraiment responsable de cette
tragédie cette tragédie c'est erdogan et
ses complices et ses ex alliés parce que
ces gens là et les quêtes millions qui
sont aux frontières syro-turque que ces
quatre millions là peuvent tout à fait
retourner chez eux les villages et les
villes ont été libérés par l'armée arabe
syrienne
monsieur erdogan et son armée ils les
retiennent ils les empêchent de
retourner dans leur village parce que
justement ça fait partie de ces leviers
politiques et du l'exercice de chantage
à l'égard de l'europe en général et du
monde ans occidentales en particulier la
turquie qui fait évidemment le rappel
partie de l'otan quand j'aime que peut
jouer l'organisation atlantique dans ce
dossier olivier delorme écouter
l'organisation avait du pacte atlantique
aujourd'hui était prisonnière de ses
propres contradictions
c'est à dire que l'on voit bien comment
monsieur erdogan a piétiné les
solidarités même fondamental de
l'alliance atlantique
même si moi je suis en tant que
gaulliste je suis un partisan de la
sortie de la france de cette
organisation
mais mais à partir du moment où on est
dans une organisation on exige de ses
membres qu'ils endurent un qu'ils ans
qu'il en reste sur les rails
finalement il ya peu de réactions
vraiment de l'otan à kaboul est la seule
réaction le temps et c'est comme quand
il ya eu la réunion de l'otan la grèce a
posé son véto à eau à l'affirmation par
l'otan de
au delà de la solidarité de l'otan avec
la turquie mais il faut aller plus loin
c'est à dire que ça voilà maintenant
depuis 1974
vous m'entendez bien depuis 1974 que à
l'intérieur de l'otan la turquie a grèce
en permanence la grèce en ne respectant
ni ses frontières maritimes ni ses
frontières aériennes ont vu moi j'habite
j'habite dans une île où douze 12 voilà
les côtes d'asie mineure sous mais sous
mes fenêtres et je peux vous dire que
l'espace aérien grec est régulièrement
violé par par les chasseurs turcs sans
que l'europe où la france ou les états
unis où l'otan ne proteste contre cet
état de fait qui force la grèce à
maintenir un effort militaire
disproportionnée par rapport à ses
positions économiques voilà depuis 1974
que la turquie occupe illégalement et
colonise illégalement 40% du territoire
de chypre membre de l'union européenne
donc si vous voulez ces organisations
internationales que sont l'otan et
l'union européenne
elles sont aujourd'hui prisonnière et
victime d'une incroyable
d'une incroyable incohérences qu'elles
ont manifesté depuis des décennies à
l'égard de la politique impérialiste
delà de la turquie et bien aujourd'hui
on est à un point de bascule de
l'histoire et il va falloir probablement
prendre des dispositions fermes si on ne
veut pas que les choses basculent dans
la catastrophe
si vous voulez les gens qui disent
aujourd'hui il faut continuer à parler
avec erdogan
c'est un peu les gens qui en 1938 disait
il faut parler avec hitler et il faut
lui céder les sudètes
je remarque d'ailleurs que monsieur
erdogan est un grand admirateur d'hitler
alors demain en tout cas il y en a un
qui va continuer à parler avec le
président turc c'est le président russe
vladimir poutine qui doit le le
rencontrer qu'est ce que on peut
attendre de cette rencontre demain
médias dad
oh je crois que l'on peut faire
confiance au président poutine
c'est un président stratège dix ans il
connaît très bien la psychologie la
psychologie et de neige dure du satrape
d'istanbul n'est ce pas et il connaît
bien sa psychologie et lui et lui il
fait de la politique justement à la
fermeté et les négociations la
diplomatie en tout cas aujourd'hui
il y a un problème majeur majeur c'est
celui de la série la série il ne lui
reste que quelques kilomètres carrés à
libérer parce que tout vient de là
finalement tout vient de cette guerre
qu'on a mené qu'on a menées sous le
prétexte fallacieux et la légende
trompeuse du printemps arabe en 2011 ça
a été une guerre armée et un soulèvement
armé immédiatement en 2011 en série au
jeu la série a tenu le coup grâce à ses
alliés mais aussi et surtout grâce à son
peuple et aux patrie et au patriotisme
de ses dirigeants aujourd'hui la série
est en train de libérer les dés
les derniers bastions n'est ce pas
arrière base de l'islam au terrorisme
que monsieur erdogan et pas seulement
lui et pas seulement lui seul y compris
certaines capitales occidentales n'est
ce pas armés aujourd'hui la guerre
l'enjeu majeur c'est l'islam au
terrorisme
et cette vague migratoire que monsieur
erdogan et tunise justement pour faire
pression et pour obtenir il joue sa
survie politique
erdogan c'est pour ça qu'il est jusqu'au
boutisme il joue sa survie politique
parce que la défaite et il y a des fêtes
c'est une question de temps et pas
seulement en séries d'ailleurs il sera
défi en libye où il a transporté déjà
des milliers d'islamistes héros rist qui
combattait en irak et en syrie sur le
territoire libyen n'est ce pas il est
des faits là il sera défait aussi
aujourd'hui il faut et c'est mieux vaut
tard que jamais parce qu'on ne joue pas
avec le jeu de avec le feu de
l'islamisme et du terrorisme je parle
des capitales occidentales
il est tant mieux vaut tard que jamais
de soutenir ces pays là qui ont mené la
guerre contre l'islam au terrorisme et
de tenir un langage ferme et résolu à
l'égard du khalife néo ottomane et
olivier lenormand il faut dire que il
faut dire que en grèce ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à la frontière ça se passe
aux cris de allahu akhbar a fait c'est à
dire que les gentils migrants qui
soi-disant viennent chercher une vie
meilleure en europe
en réalité
il ya là dedans beaucoup de beaucoup de
combattants que monsieur erdogan amène
de syrie comme il en a mais n'en comme
il en a mais n'en leary en libye écrit
qu'on est incapable aujourd'hui de ceux
de savoir parmi ces migrants combien il
y en a qui demain commettront des
attentats en europe occidentale si il
passe là s'ils passent cette frontière
il faut dire aussi saluer la presse
occidentale a une tout autre lecture que
la désinformation totale sur comment est
ce que vous dénoncez une baisse en un an
je promets et j'espère deux hommes se
sait je pose des questions demain et que
cette presse ne dit pas et cash qui lie
à aujourd'hui en grâce des dizaines
d'églises orthodoxes qui sont saccagées
par les par les soi-disant gentil
migrants qui sont déjà rentrés sur le
territoire turc
cette journée un grand culation voile
viande qui dans cette affaire si la
manipulation à dire un mot sur al akhbar
chaque fois ça y est vous pensez vous
que parce que c'est de l'art et la lie
allahou akbar c'est un mot clé dans la
religion musulmane qui est la mienne
c'est un appel à la prière
c'est une reconnaissance de l'unicité
divine de c'est une reconnaissance de la
transcendance divine de la grandeur de
les islamo terroriste et moi je dirais
également les islamofascistes ont fait
de ce de cet appel à la prière et à la
transcendance un appel pour égorger des
êtres humains et là je pense
particulièrement à la tragédie que le
peuple syrien a subi pendant quasiment
neuf années voyez-vous là la totalité je
dirais 99% des musulmans dans le monde
ne sont pas ces monstres qui non
seulement ont commis des crimes contre
l'humanité soutenu par certains et pas
dit civilisé
mais ils ont aussi souliers de l'heure
sur la religion qui est la mienne et qui
est celle de plus d'un milliard de
musulmans dans le monde
merci en tout cas messieurs olivier
delorme médias d'avoir été avec nous
nous avoir apporté votre point de vue en
direct sur rt france reste